¡Ya llegaron los helados!
La siguiente tabla describe el número de
bolas en un cono de helado
(representado por "x")
y el precio del cono  (representado por "y")
Escribe la ecuación que representa esta relación.
Bien, entonces, aquí en la tabla, el número
de bolas sería "x"
y el de precio que pagó por el
cono de helado sería "y", ok.
Antes que nada voy a convertir todos estos
número mixtos en fracciones propias o bueno,
más bien impropias.
1 con 3/4 ¿cuánto es?
Pues es 1 más 3/4, así que si lo pongo con
denominador 4 sería lo mismo que 4 por 1
es 4, más 3 es 7, 7/4.
3 con 1/2 es lo mismo que 2 por 3 es 6 más 1 = 7, 7/2, si lo escribo con denominador 4,
tengo que multiplicar el numerador y denominador
por 2 y obtengo 14/4.
5 con 1/4 sería lo mismo
que 4 por 5 es 20 más 1 = 21/4.
Y finalmente 7, escrito con denominador 4,
sería lo mismo que 28/4.
Muy bien, ahora si estamos listos para encontrar
la ecuación que representa la relación.
Pues noten, que esta relación es proporcional
y que de hecho, "x" entre "y"... perdón...
y que de hecho "y" entre "x", siempre tiene
el mismo valor,
¿y qué valor es ese?
Pues este valor es... este valor es, 7/4.
Noten que cuando "y" vale 7/4, "x" vale 1,
por lo tanto, 7/4 entre 1 es 7/4.
Cuando "x" vale 14/4... perdón cuando "y"
vale 14/4... cuando "y" vale 14/4,
eso dividido entre 2 es de nuevo a 7/4, por lo tanto
esta relación es proporcional.
Otro modo de escribir esto, podría decir
si multiplico todo por "x",
podría mutiplicar aquí por "x" y acá también por "x"
y escribir esto como, pues esta "x" cancela esta "x"
y resulta que "y"... "y" es igual a... es
igual a 7/4 de "x"... "y" es igual a 7/4 de "x"
y podemos verificarlo.
Cuando "x"vale 0, "y" vale 0, que sería lo
mismo si sustituyo esos valores aquí.
Cuando "x" vale 4, entonces "y" vale 7 por
4 entre 4, que sería lo mismo que 7,
así que esto funciona.
Vamos a verificarlo.
Bueno, así que solo vamos a escribir aquí,
"y" es igual a 7 entre 4 por "x" y chequemos.
¡Muy bien!